Of all the things in the movies that could happen to you-- and there's so many, right-- I think getting shrunk down to a miniature size-- I think that is one that nobody would ever choose. It seems dangerous. It seems frightening. How Marvel Comics ever thought that shrinking could be a superpower, that is really totally beyond me. Turning yourself into a person the size of a pencil eraser? It doesn't make anything easier. Everything is harder. In the movie Ant-Man, the first time Ant-Man shrinks--
在电影里，可能发生在人身上的事那么多，其中我最不想选的一种，恐怕就是把自己缩小了。这看起来很危险，也很可怕。我真的搞不懂漫威漫画是怎么把“缩小”设定成超能力的。把自己变成铅笔橡皮那么大？这并不会让事情变简单，反而一切都更难了。在电影《蚁人》里，蚁人第一次缩小的时候——
What is this?
这是什么？
--he's instantly in mortal danger. Water in a bathtub nearly drowns him.
——他瞬间就陷入了致命危险。浴缸里的水差点让他溺毙。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
People dancing in an apartment almost crush him with their high-heeled shoes. A rat tries to eat him.
公寓里跳舞的人差点用高跟鞋把他踩扁。还有只老鼠想吃掉他。
[GROWLING]
[低吼声]
It's a ridiculous superpower. The writers actually have to cheat and give Ant-Man a whole second power, mind control over armies of ants, or he'd never get anything accomplished. But these stories of tiny people, you know, Honey I Shrunk the Kids, The Borrowers-- when I was young, I loved the film Fantastic Voyage-- I do get the appeal of them. They give you this feeling of what if. What if I was so small that I could stand between the wafers of an Oreo cookie, that I could climb onto an insect?
这是一种荒谬的超能力。编剧实际上必须作弊，给蚁人加了第二个超能力，即用意念控制蚁群，否则他什么都干不成。但这些关于微小人类的故事，比如《亲爱的，我把孩子缩小了》、《借东西的小人》——我小时候很喜欢电影《神奇旅程》——我确实理解它们的吸引力。它们让你产生一种“假如”的感觉。假如我变得那么小，能站在奥利奥饼干夹心中间，能爬上一只昆虫，那会怎样？
Last year, when she was in fourth grade, Chloe thought about this a lot. She's a kid in suburban New Jersey. Now that she's in fifth grade, she finds this a little embarrassing. But last year, every night when she'd go to bed, she'd prepare for the possibility that magic might strike while she was asleep, and that she would shrink down to the size of her dollhouse. Those preparations included--
去年，克洛伊（Chloe）上四年级时，经常思考这个问题。她是新泽西郊区的一个孩子。现在她上五年级了，觉得这事有点尴尬。但去年，她每天晚上睡觉前，都会为梦中可能发生的奇迹做准备——她可能会缩小到她玩偶屋那么大。那些准备工作包括——
I would sleep on the edge of my pillow. It's like the very top of my head is on the pillow, and then the rest of my body is on my bed.
我会睡在枕头的边缘。就是头顶刚好在枕头上，身体的其他部分在床上。
That way, if she shrunk in the middle of the night, she would be on the bed and not on the pillow, which seemed way more treacherous to her. She also took a slap bracelet, which can stretch out like a ruler, and positioned the ruler very carefully, like a little bridge, from--
这样，如果她在半夜缩小了，她就会在床上而不是枕头上，因为枕头对她来说看起来太凶险了。她还拿了一个拍拍手环，可以像尺子一样拉直，然后小心翼翼地把这把尺子架在——
The edge of my bed to the edge of my bedside table.
从床边到床头柜边缘。
And why?
为什么？
To walk from my bed to my bedside table where I had the little hammock
为了从床上走到床头柜上，那里有我的小吊床。
The little hammock, which she made for herself to sleep on, which is basically a bracelet of intertwined rubber bands suspended in air on a frame of Q-tips.
那个小吊床是她自己做的，基本上就是用棉签搭个架子，悬挂起一个由彩色橡皮筋编织而成的手环。
And then I also had a little couch, and the couch was on the bedside table. So you walk past the ruler. You turn left, you'll see the couch. And if you go a little beyond that, you'll see the hammock.
然后我还有一个小沙发，沙发就在床头柜上。所以你走过那把尺子，向左转，就能看到沙发。再往远走一点，就能看到吊床。
Under the hammock was a calculator that she could step on, like a little footstool, to get up onto the hammock. And next to the couch was a Post-it folded in half with a note to her parents explaining that she had shrunk, all ready to be unfolded when this really happened to her for real. And finally, every night when she went to bed--
吊床下面有个计算器，她可以像踩脚凳一样踩上去，爬进吊床。沙发旁边有一张对折的便利贴，上面写给父母的纸条，解释说她变小了，如果真的发生这种情况，她随时可以把纸条展开。最后，她每天晚上上床时——
I took some of the really important things to me, put them in a blanket, and then held onto the blanket every night, hoping that it would turn small with me.
我会把对我来说最重要的一些东西拿来，放在毯子里，然后每天晚上紧紧抱着毯子，希望它能和我一起变小。
So what would be wrapped up in the blanket?
那毯子里会裹着什么呢？
My stuffed animal, Boo, my cat stuffed animal, one of my books, and a couple other stuffed animals.
我的毛绒玩具“布”（Boo），我的猫咪毛绒玩具，还有我的一本书，以及其他几个毛绒玩具。
And were you hoping that this would happen, or were you fearing that this would happen, that you would get small? [BEEPING]
你是希望发生这种事，还是害怕发生这种事，即你会变小？[哔哔声]
I was both.
两者都有。
That beeping that you're hearing-- Chloe was being recorded on a telephone whose batteries started dying at this point in the interview, making that beeping noise.
你听到的哔哔声——克洛伊当时正在用电话接受采访，采访中途电话没电了，发出了这种声音。
Tell me the hope; tell me the fear.
告诉我你希望的部分，告诉我你害怕的部分。
The hope because then I would get to live in my dollhouse, which, it had a little swing on the porch. It's cool. And I wouldn't have to watch Netflix with my sister. And every popcorn would be a meal.
希望是因为那样我就能住进我的玩偶屋了，那里门廊上还有个小秋千。很酷。而且我就不用跟姐姐一起看Netflix了。每一粒爆米花都能吃上一顿饭。
So that's the hope. What was the fear?
那是希望。那害怕的是什么？
The fear was my parents wouldn't be able to hug me. I might not have electronics. I wouldn't be able to see my friends, because I would be tiny. And I wouldn't be able to go to the pool.
害怕的是爸爸妈妈抱不了我。我可能没有电子产品。我见不到朋友，因为我太小了。而且我也去不了游泳池。
[LAUGHS] You wouldn't be able to swim anymore.
[笑] 你再也不能游泳了。
Yeah, well, my mom could just set up a little bowl.
嗯，我妈妈可以给我准备个小碗。
Yeah. I was going to say, she could just take a tray of water and just put it out for you.
没错。我正想说，她可以拿个水盘放在那儿。
Yeah.
嗯。
Once you start to think about the world this way, small stuff can become really transfixing. The sheer tinyness of tiny things can have a kind of mesmerizing power to it. We were talking about this at our office last week, and Bim took the most extreme stand on this. I dragged her into the studio to talk about this.
一旦你开始以这种方式看待世界，细小的事物就会变得非常迷人。微小之物的纯粹感可能拥有一种催眠的力量。上周我们在办公室讨论这个时，比姆（Bim）对此持最极端的观点。我把她拉进演播室聊了聊。
I just like generally small things. If there is a small version of a thing, I am interested in seeing it or reading about it or hearing about it.
我通常就是喜欢小东西。如果有个东西有微缩版，我就很有兴趣去看、去读或去听。
It's Bim who told me about the radically tiny tubs of Vaseline you can buy, which have the exact design of the bigger jars.
就是比姆告诉我，你可以买到极小的凡士林罐，它们的设计和大罐的一模一样。
It's about the size of my thumbnail, maybe my thumbnail and a half. They're very small. They're very cute. They don't look like they're real. They look like ornaments that you might hang from a Christmas tree.
大概只有我的指甲盖那么大，或者一个半指甲盖。它们非常小，非常可爱。看起来不像真的，倒像挂在圣诞树上的装饰品。
And what you like about them is--
你喜欢它们是因为——
What I like about them is just how small they are. They seem almost pointless. You can find Vaseline in any number of other sizes. The fact that this exists-- I think it feels like somebody-- yeah, it was just a pointless gesture. Let's make Vaseline even smaller. Can you imagine them looking across at one another and kind of going, hey, should we make this smaller? And someone said, there's no need. And they were like, precisely.
我喜欢它们单纯是因为它们太小了。它们看起来几乎毫无意义。你完全可以找到其他任何尺寸的凡士林。这个东西的存在——我觉得它感觉就像有人——是的，这只是个毫无意义的举动。让我们把凡士林做得更小一点吧。你能想象他们面面相觑说：“嘿，我们把它做小点儿吗？”然后有人说：“没必要。”他们就说：“没错，就是这样。”
And I think small things, by nature, are whimsical. They just feel like, oh, you didn't have to be. You didn't have to exist, but here you are. And that's what makes them kind of joyful.
我觉得小东西本质上是奇思妙想的。它们给人的感觉就像是：“哦，你本来不必存在的，但你却在这里。”这就是让它们显得有趣的原因。
They're just things for the pleasure of smallness and staring at smallness.
它们只是为了享受微小本身，并凝视微小之物而存在的东西。
It's like when you look at broccoli, and you think, oh, I'm a giant, and this is a small tree. It's that feeling. I'm almost 40.
就像你看西兰花时，心想：哦，我是个巨人，这是一棵小树。就是那种感觉。我快40岁了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Do you still have that feeling? You'll look at a broccoli, and you'll think it's like a small tree?
你还有那种感觉吗？你会看着西兰花，把它当作一棵小树吗？
I don't still have that feeling. I used to have that feeling when I was a child. I will not be mocked. [LAUGHS]
我没有那种感觉了。我小时候有过那种感觉。我才不会被嘲笑呢。[笑]
No one has mocked you yet.
还没有人嘲笑你。
Your face.
你的表情出卖了你。
Well, today on our program, "Small Things Considered," we have stories of people overlooking what is so great about the tiny, the minuscule, the peewee, the bite size, and the teensy-weensy. Also, some very dramatic examples of the power of smallness, including, for instance, the power to end health insurance as we know it for millions of people.
好的，今天在我们的节目《细微考量》中，我们将讲述人们如何审视那些伟大的细微、极小、侏儒、一口大小和微不足道的事物。此外，还有一些关于微小力量的戏剧性例子，例如，它有终结数百万普通人医疗保险的力量。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. My voice is affected by some sort of tiny, tiny bug this week. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《此美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。这周我的嗓子被某种极微小的虫子感染了。请继续收听。
Act 1, Coming Up Short.
第一幕：缩水了。
So a while ago, we got an email from a physician who was starting to see a trend that disturbed her, among her patients. She wanted us to look into it. We thought our contributor Scott Brown would be the best person for the job for reasons that'll become clear as he proceeds. Here's Scott.
前阵子，我们收到一位医生的电子邮件，她发现病人中出现了一种令她不安的趋势。她希望我们调查一下。我们认为我们的撰稿人斯科特·布朗（Scott Brown）是最佳人选，原因随着他的深入报道会变得清晰。下面是斯科特。
So this doctor told us that all of these parents have been coming to her, scads of them-- she used the word inundated-- with the same problem. Their kids were short, not dramatically short. They were just below average height for their age. We're talking 9-, 10-, 11-year-old kids. And what these parents wanted was for this doctor to prescribe them human growth hormone injections to make their kids taller.
这位医生告诉我们，大量的父母——她用了“淹没”这个词——来找她，问题都一样。他们的孩子长得矮，不是那种极度矮小，只是低于同龄人的平均身高。我说的是9岁、10岁、11岁的孩子。父母们想要的是医生给孩子开人类生长激素注射液，好让他们长高。
These are daily injections that cost tens of thousands of dollars a year. It's usually affluent privileged families, this doctor says, who already have all the advantages. She went as far as to call the desire for growth hormone among these folks an epidemic.
这些是每天的注射剂，每年花费数万美元。这位医生说，这通常是那些已经拥有所有优势的富裕特权家庭。她甚至将这些人对生长激素的渴望称为“流行病”。
Because I've had parents come to me and say, "Everyone I know is on growth hormone." That was an actual quote. Everyone I know is on this stuff. Or, it's all the rage in this anonymous community, a very affluent community.
因为有父母来找我说：“我认识的所有人都打了生长激素。”这是原话。我认识的每个人都打了这玩意。或者说，在一个匿名社区里，在一个非常富裕的社区里，这正风靡一时。
This doctor want it to be completely anonymous, by the way. She feels like she's whistleblowing. In fact, this isn't her real voice. We swapped her voice for an actor's in our recording of the interview. Since I can't identify her, I'll refer to her from here on as Short Throat. All we can say is she's a pediatric endocrinologist-- that is, a children's doctor, specializing in stuff like diabetes, thyroid problems, and growth.
顺便说一下，这位医生希望完全匿名。她觉得自己像个举报人。事实上，这不是她真实的声音。我们在采访录音中把她的声音换成了演员的声音。因为我不能暴露她，所以从现在起我称她为“短嗓”。我们只能透露她是儿科内分泌学家，也就是研究糖尿病、甲状腺问题和生长发育的儿童医生。
She says she got into medicine to treat sick kids, but fully half of her patients are coming to her just for the growth part.
她说她从医是为了治疗生病的孩子，但她的病人中有一半仅仅是为了长高而来。
So parents will find out one kid is being treated and assume that their child, because they're below average, needs it too. Like, oh, if they're doing it, then am I going to be missing out? In fact, I think the phrase one mom used was something like, I'm just trying to be proactive and worried, I don't miss my window of opportunity.
父母们发现一个孩子在接受治疗，就假设自己的孩子因为低于平均身高，也需要治疗。就像：“哦，如果别人在做，那我是不是错失了机会？”事实上，我想一位母亲用的词大致是：“我只是想未雨绸缪，担心错失我的窗口期。”
That window is real. Parents have to start their kids on the drug by the time they're hitting puberty. Short Throat has been practicing for about seven years, but she works closely with other doctors who've been at it for decades.
那个窗口期是真实存在的。父母必须在孩子进入青春期之前给他们用药。短嗓执业大约七年了，但她与许多从业几十年的医生密切合作。
And they do say that it's gotten much, much worse. Like, they don't remember anything like this. One of my senior colleagues, it's almost like she's surprised every time. I can't believe this kid came in here. Look at this growth chart. And I walk in the office, and it's a kid growing at the 40th percentile with parents who are the 40th percentile.
他们确实说情况变得糟糕多了。他们不记得以前有过这种事。我的一位资深同事，每次见到这种情况都感到很惊讶。“我不敢相信这个孩子来这儿。看看这张生长发育表。”我走进办公室，发现是一个生长在第40百分位的孩子，父母也处于第40百分位。
40th percentile, meaning 40% of the rest of the country is shorter than they are, so just below average.
第40百分位，意味着全国有40%的人比他们矮，所以只是略低于平均水平。
And she's like, can you believe they're here for growth? And I'm like, yes, I can believe that because-- this is, like, everyday you call me in and are flabbergasted by the same thing.
她说：“你能相信他们是来求助生长发育问题的吗？”我说：“是的，我可以相信，因为——每天你都把我叫进来，对同样的事情感到目瞪口呆。”
I had a conversation where I had a patient come see me. Her son was 5 foot, 7". Mom was 5' 4". Dad was 5' 8". They wanted treatment. If you say something to them like, well, his predicted height is 5' 9", you might get a response that's something like, well, that's unacceptable.
我曾有过一次谈话，一个病人来找我。她儿子5英尺7英寸（约170厘米）。妈妈5英尺4英寸，爸爸5英尺8英寸。他们想要治疗。如果你对他们说：“好吧，他预测身高是5英尺9英寸。”你可能会得到这样的回应：“这不可接受。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
You're laughing, but that's my job.
你在笑，但这就是我的工作。
I'm laughing for so many different reasons.
我笑是因为很多不同的原因。
Do you get it now?
你现在懂了吗？
Oh, I get it. I've gotten it my whole life. This is probably the point in the story where I should level with you, if I could-- short joke! I'm just under 5' 3", which puts me right around the first percentile of American males by height, shorter than 99% of the men in this country. For years, I thought I was 5' 4"-- the second percentile. But a recent doctor visit confirmed that I'd been rounding up.
哦，我懂。我这辈子一直都懂。这可能是故事里我该坦白的时候，如果可以的话——矮个子笑话！我只有5英尺3英寸多一点，在美国男性身高百分比中大概处于第一百分位，比全国99%的男性都矮。多年来我一直以为我是5英尺4英寸——第二百分位。但最近的一次医生检查确认我一直是在四舍五入。
I've always been the smallest guy in the room, consistently smaller than other kids, for as long as I can remember. There are some downsides, sure. But I think I have a pretty good life. My successes and failures-- I do not leave them at the tiny feet of my shortness. My height is just one thing about me, not the thing, not the defining thing.
我一直是房间里最小的男人，只要我有记忆以来，一直比别的孩子小。当然有一些坏处。但我认为我的生活还不错。我的成功和失败——我不会把它们归咎于我矮小的双脚。我的身高只是我的一部分，不是全部，不是决定性的。
But recently, I wrote a young adult novel about a 16-year-old boy who's 4 foot 11" and struggling with his identity. And I found myself thinking every day about being short-- what it meant to me, what it might have meant, what I might have missed. And then I hear from this doctor about all of these parents who think having a son my size is unacceptable and come to her to fix it, to fix them.
但最近，我写了一部关于一个4英尺11英寸、在身份认同中挣扎的16岁男孩的青年小说。我发现我每天都在思考“矮”这件事——它对我意味着什么，可能意味着什么，我可能错过了什么。然后我就听到这位医生说，所有这些父母都认为有一个像我这么大的儿子是不可接受的，并来找她解决问题，修理他们。
Short Throat tells the families who just want to enhance their kid's height that she won't do that, but that doesn't always stop them.
短嗓告诉那些只想提升孩子身高的家庭，她不会这么做，但这并不总能阻止他们。
There are some private practice pediatric endocrinologists in our area who-- the phrase I've used is I feel like they would give growth hormone to a rock if you asked them to-- like, sitting people down and giving them the worst-case scenario height prediction, and then being, like, this is what you need, and then treating them.
在我们地区有一些私立儿科内分泌医生——我用过的措辞是，我觉得如果你要求，他们甚至会给石头打生长激素——他们会让人们坐下，给出最坏情况的身高预测，然后说：“这就是你需要的。”然后开始治疗。
Oh, so their consult is part of saying, you don't want this short kid here. You know?
哦，所以他们的咨询就是为了让你觉得，你不希望有个矮个子孩子待在这里。你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You don't want a hobbit.
你不想要个霍比特人。
Oh, absolutely. That's what the paren-- I know the prescribing practices of all of others peds endos in our area. Because people bounce around, and they doctor shop, and they want other opinions.
哦，绝对。我知道我们地区所有其他儿科内分泌医生的处方习惯。因为人们会到处转，货比三家，他们想要其他意见。
Among the things that bother her the most, a lot of the parents seem oblivious to the possibility of side effects. But really, the biggest bee in Short Throat's growth hormone bonnet is the fairness aspect. The full treatment over four or five years can cost $300,000 or more.
在让她最困扰的事情中，许多父母似乎对副作用的可能性视而不见。但说真的，短嗓对生长激素最看不惯的还是公平性问题。为期四五年的全面治疗可能花费30万美元甚至更多。
And even though most of these families are rich, they find ways to get it covered by insurance when some of her diabetic patients can't even get the latest insulin pump covered. She also says she's seen rich families take advantage of patient assistance programs the drug companies offer to needier folks.
尽管这些家庭大多数都很富有，但他们总能找到让保险公司承保的方法，而她的一些糖尿病患者甚至无法报销最新的胰岛素泵。她还说，她看到富裕家庭利用制药公司为穷人提供的患者援助计划。
I've seen affluent patients get on these, quote, unquote, "patient assistance programs" when-- OK, this is terrible-- but sometimes I will Zillow their house. And I'll be like, you live in a $6 million home, and you're getting patient assistance for your kid's growth hormone. Gross, gross, just gross.
我见过富裕的病人利用这些所谓的“患者援助计划”，而——天哪，这太糟糕了——但有时我会去查询他们的房产估值。我会想：你住在价值600万美元的豪宅里，却在为你孩子的生长激素申请患者援助。恶心，恶心，真是太恶心了。
It's important to say, Short Throat does treat some kids with growth hormone-- kids who aren't producing enough of it or any of it on their own. That's a serious health problem. But she'll also treat them if a kid is just going to be really, really short, like way, way below average, like way down in those basement percentiles where I am.
必须说，短嗓确实会用生长激素治疗一些孩子——那些自身生长激素分泌不足或完全不分泌的孩子。那是一个严重的健康问题。但如果一个孩子真的非常非常矮，远低于平均水平，比如像我处于那些最低的百分位，她也会治疗。
Using growth hormone is kosher in cases like this according to the FDA. That's because there's a diagnosis for people like me. I learned about it while researching my book. It's called Idiopathic Short Stature, ISS. Sounds scary, but all it means is I'm short, and no one knows why. And because I fit that diagnosis, I could have been one of Short Throat's patients.
根据FDA的规定，在这些情况下使用生长激素是合法的。这是因为像我这样的人有一个诊断结果。我在研究我的书时了解到的。这叫“特发性矮小症”（ISS）。听起来很吓人，但意思只是我矮，而且没人知道为什么。因为我符合那个诊断，所以我本来也可能是短嗓的病人。
So yes, even our whistleblower, who believes this stuff is overused, would've treated me if I'd come to her, if my parents had wanted it. And as one of those otherwise healthy kids who are just short, and who kind of resents the use of the word otherwise, I'd add, all of this looks not a whole lot like medicine. It looks cosmetic, like a boob job for kids, short kids.
所以是的，即使是我们这个举报人，那个认为这玩意被过度使用的人，如果我当时去找她，如果我父母想要的话，她也会治疗我。作为一个本来健康但仅仅是矮的孩子，而且有点反感“本来”这个词的使用，我会补充说，这一切看起来一点都不像医学。它看起来很像美容，就像给孩子——矮个子孩子——做的隆胸手术。
But before I went off on a Napoleonic rage bender over the claims of this one rogue grow doctor, I thought I'd run those claims by Dr. David B. Allen, another pediatric endocrinologist, and arguably, the leading expert on this topic. He sat on the panel that wrote the recent guidelines for growth hormone treatments for kids. He's been writing papers about it for three decades, specifically, about idiopathic short stature.
但在我因为这个黑心医生的主张而爆发那种拿破仑式的愤怒之前，我想把这些说法拿去问问大卫·B·艾伦（David B. Allen）医生，另一位儿科内分泌学家，可以说也是这个领域的主要专家。他曾是编写近期儿童生长激素治疗指南委员会的成员。他研究这个话题已经三十年了，特别是特发性矮小症。
You actually-- not to get personal, but you sound like you do fit the diagnosis. You may.
你其实——不是想跟你套近乎，但你听起来确实符合这个诊断。你可能就是。
Did you just diagnose me over the radio?
你刚才是通过广播给我下诊断了吗？
It's amazing. I've got a lot of experience.
太神奇了。我有很多经验。
He said he didn't think unnecessary growth hormone treatments for kids was an epidemic, per se. The reluctance of insurance companies to cover such an expensive and iffy treatment keeps widespread use tamped down. But sure, there are lots of families in more image-conscious, wealthy places who put their kids on it.
他说他不认为对儿童进行不必要的生长激素治疗是一种“流行病”。保险公司对这种昂贵且效果不确定的治疗方案的抵触，限制了其广泛应用。但当然，在很多注重形象的富裕地区，有很多家庭给孩子用药。
When he writes about using growth hormone for height, not health, the phrase he uses is cosmetic endocrinology. And he told me this story. Back in the day, growth hormone was used almost exclusively on kids who were growth hormone-deficient, the way you give insulin to a diabetic. And the only source for this stuff back then was the pituitary glands of cadavers, dead people, so the supply was limited.
当他写到为了身高而非健康使用生长激素时，他用的词是“美容内分泌学”。他给我讲了这样一个故事。在过去，生长激素几乎只用于生长激素缺乏的孩子，就像给糖尿病患者注射胰岛素一样。当时这种东西的唯一来源是尸体的垂体。所以供应非常有限。
Unfortunately, because it came from cadavers, some of it was tainted with a brain disease similar to Mad Cow. It was a freak thing. This was in the '80s. Dozens of young people got sick. Some of them died. But that same year, synthetic growth hormone became available. Now there was lots of the stuff-- lab-made, safe from contamination. Dr. Allen told me and my producer, Sean Cole, that the drug industry and doctors started looking around for other uses, like, say, making idiopathically short kids less idiopathically short.
不幸的是，因为它是来源于尸体，其中一些被类似疯牛病的脑部疾病污染了。这是一种极其罕见的意外。那是在80年代。几十个年轻人病倒了。其中一些死了。但在同一年，合成生长激素上市了。现在东西多了——实验室制造，没有污染。艾伦医生告诉我和我的制片人肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole），制药行业和医生开始寻找其他用途，比如，让那些特发性矮小的孩子不再那么特发性矮小。
Idiopathic short stature really became a thing once there was growth hormone treatment available that might work. It was a descriptive term. Of course, it's been a descriptive term for a long, long time. But as a diagnosis, I think it was more really after there was a treatment available. It's one of these situations where it's almost like a treatment that's in search of a diagnosis.
特发性矮小症只有在有了可能有效的生长激素治疗后才真正成为一种“事物”。它以前是一个描述性术语。当然，它作为描述性术语存在了很久很久。但作为一种诊断，我认为它是在有了治疗方案之后才真正出现的。这属于那种“为了治疗方案而寻找诊断”的情况。
So a solution in search of a problem.
所以是为解决问题而寻找的问题。
Sort of. Yes, right, exactly.
算是吧。是的，没错，正是如此。
And also, why are we treating shortness like it's a disease? Because when you look into it, as researchers have, there's no evidence tying being short to having a bad life. Studies show short kids get teased, bullied. They're often treated as younger than they are. But there's no direct connection between being small and failing at life. I, for instance, did not end up depressed and alone, living in a tiny cardboard box behind Bob's Big Boy, at least, not because of my height.
而且，为什么我们要把矮小当作一种疾病来对待？因为当你像研究人员那样深入研究时，没有证据表明矮小与生活不顺有关。研究表明矮个子孩子会受到戏弄、欺负。他们经常被当作比实际年龄小的人对待。但变小与生活失败之间没有直接联系。比如，我并没有最终变得抑郁、孤独，住在鲍勃汉堡店后面一个狭小的纸箱里，至少不是因为我的身高。
Another thing Dr. Allen said is that the use of synthetic growth hormone in kids is generally agreed to be safe. But he said, it just hasn't been on the market long enough for us to know yet. There could be an increased risk of cancer down the road. One study, and only one, points to more instances of stroke among adults who took the drug as children.
艾伦医生说的另一件事是，在儿童身上使用合成生长激素通常被认为安全。但他表示，它上市时间还不够长，我们还不知道。未来可能会增加患癌风险。有一项研究，仅仅是一项，指出那些在童年时期服用该药物的成年人中，中风的案例更多。
Thing is, we won't really know how dangerous this stuff is until 30, or 40, or 50 years down the line. Also, on average, kids who take growth hormone might gain three inches, a little less than half an inch per year, but that's average. Your heightage may vary a lot, could be more, could be less. I'll just note that less than a little less than 1/2 inch a year would be a very sad title for a country song.
问题是，在30年、40年或50年之后，我们才会真正知道这玩意有多危险。另外，平均而言，服用生长激素的孩子可能会长高3英寸（约7.6厘米），每年不到半英寸，但那是平均值。你的身高增长可能差异很大，可能更多，也可能更少。我只想说，每年增长不到半英寸听起来会是一个乡村音乐里非常悲伤的歌名。
The darkest irony here is Dr. Allen says the kids you'd think need the drug the most, kids with short parents, are the ones who benefit the least.
这里最黑暗的讽刺是，艾伦医生说你认为最需要这种药的孩子，即父母矮小的孩子，反而是获益最少的。
And it's conceivable that there are some risks that we don't yet know about or are just learning about 20 years down the road, that this completely healthy 10-year-old has now been exposed to, for a benefit that we have a lot of difficulty documenting. That, to me, that's the conundrum, right?
可以想象，存在一些我们还不知道或者才刚开始了解到的风险，这导致一个完全健康的10岁孩子现在暴露在风险中，而我们很难证明其收益。这对我来说，就是一个难题，对吧？
Not a conundrum for me. The health effects are unknown, benefits uncertain, and even if you get taller, you're not necessarily happier? Then I'm not putting my kid on it, not for a maximum 3 inches total, not for 1/2 inch a year. Who would choose that for their kid? I decided to find out.
对我来说不是难题。健康影响未知，收益不确定，而且即使你长高了，也不一定更快乐？那我就不会给我孩子用它，为了总共最多3英寸的身高，为了每年不到半英寸的增长。谁会为自己的孩子做这种选择？我决定去一探究竟。
Are you going to call this growth hormone gate? Is that what you're going to call it?
你打算管这叫“生长激素门”吗？你打算这么叫吗？
That sounds snappy. We should definitely do that.
听起来挺时髦。我们绝对该这么叫。
[?  ?] It's funny, because--
[？] 真有意思，因为——
I can't tell you any of these folks' names, either. They're in Southern California. I'll call the dad Jeremy. He's a doctor. He's 5 foot 8". The mom, who I'll call Laura, is 5 foot 4". She's a personal development coach. There are two kids, Dylan and Marnie, also not their real names. Dylan's been taking growth hormone injections for five years. We asked Laura why they wanted to be anonymous.
我也不能告诉你这些人的名字。他们住在南加州。我管这位父亲叫杰里米（Jeremy）。他是个医生，5英尺8英寸。母亲我管她叫劳拉（Laura），5英尺4英寸。她是个人成长教练。有两个孩子，迪伦（Dylan）和玛尼（Marnie），也不是真名。迪伦已经注射生长激素五年了。我们问劳拉他们为什么要匿名。
It's a little embarrassing. Most of his, probably, peers don't know. His close friends know. But for a girl, it's cute if she's short and petite. But for a guy, it kind of says something about your masculinity. So I just wanted to protect him for whatever reasons-- short-term, long-term.
这有点尴尬。他大多数同学可能都不知道。他的好朋友知道。但对女孩子来说，矮小娇小很可爱。但对男孩子来说，这某种程度上代表了你的男子气概。所以我只是想保护他，不管是什么原因——短期还是长期的。
They all live in a big, beautiful house with a pool that contains what I'm fairly sure is a water polo goal. Dylan's on the team. The living room is immaculate, like the lobby of a luxury hotel. When we got there, there was a dog-grooming van sitting out front in which their dog was being groomed. She looked nice afterwards.
他们都住在一栋宽敞漂亮的房子里，带游泳池，里面很确定有一个水球门。迪伦在队里。客厅一尘不染，像豪华酒店的大堂。我们到的时候，前面停着一辆狗狗美容车，他们的狗正在里面美容。她后来看起来很漂亮。
Laura's been worrying about Dylan's size since he was a baby. He was born preemie-sized, even though she carried him full-term. He spent four or five days in the NICU. And as he got older, it just seemed like he was having a hard time catching up to his friends in the height department. He was the smallest in his team photos, class photos, always an outlier. So when she found out there was something that might help fix that, it just felt like the right call.
劳拉从迪伦还是婴儿时就开始担心他的身高。他出生时是早产儿尺寸，尽管劳拉足月分娩。他在新生儿重症监护室待了四五天。随着他长大，他似乎在身高方面很难赶上朋友。他在队里的合照、班级合照里总是最小的，一直是个局外人。所以当她发现有什么东西可以帮助改善这一点时，这感觉就是正确的决定。
To me, it was just a medical choice, and it was never aesthetic. It just was more medical, and I don't know if--
对我来说，这只是个医疗选择，从来不是美观问题。它更多是医疗上的，我不知道——
It's interesting. We have slightly different views and perceptions.
有趣的是，我们的观点和看法略有不同。
Again, this is Jeremy. He's a doctor, so you'd expect him to come at this from a medical necessity point of view, too, and he does. But he's totally upfront about his less doctor-y reasons.
再次强调，这是杰里米。他是医生，所以你也会期望他从医疗必要性的角度来看待这个问题，他也确实如此。但他完全坦诚自己那些没那么“医生”的动机。
I don't know. Stereotypical-- I'm a guy. I want him to be big and strong, if he can be bigger and stronger.
我不知道。刻板印象——我是个男人。我希望他能长得高大强壮，如果他能变得更强壮。
But to get to that, the risk factor had to be eliminated. And so what was the point where you were like, well, now we can start thinking about bigger and stronger because I am satisfied that whatever long-term studies they are looking for--
但要实现这一点，必须排除风险因素。那么，你是从什么时候开始觉得：“好吧，现在我们可以开始考虑变得高大强壮，因为我确信他们所研究的任何长期研究——”
There was a risk. I had to kind of take it. At least it wasn't my life, so I wasn't worried. No, I'm just kidding. Just, no.
是有风险的。我必须承担它。至少不是我的命，所以我没那么担心。不，开玩笑的。只是，没有。
[INAUDIBLE] punch you in this interview.
[听不清] 这次采访真想揍你一拳。
I'm sorry. No, it was a risk. It's not easy making that decision. Like, gosh, I'm putting my son at risk for diabetes? My brother has diabetes. I see it.
对不起。不，这是个风险。做这个决定并不容易。比如，天哪，我在拿我儿子的糖尿病风险开玩笑吗？我哥哥有糖尿病。我见过。
Just to point out, the risk of diabetes from pediatric growth hormone use is more theoretical than anything else. Doctors monitor for it, but so far, there's no causal link.
顺便提一下，儿童使用生长激素导致的糖尿病风险更多是理论上的。医生会监测，但到目前为止，没有因果联系。
So there was a little bit in the back of my mind, like, oh, boy, what did I just do to my son? Something may have happened that would have been irreversible. And so I would have just never forgiven myself had it happened. There's no question. It was in the back of my brain. I'm a doctor, so I get it.
所以我的脑海深处确实有一点：“哦，天哪，我刚才对我儿子做了什么？”有些事情可能已经发生了，并且是不可逆转的。如果真的发生了，我永远不会原谅自己。毫无疑问。它就在我的脑海深处。我是医生，所以我懂。
I didn't think about it [INAUDIBLE].
我没想过它 [听不清]。
I've worried about it in the back of my brain. I just don't verbalize it. But knock on wood, fortunately, he's been fine, and all we've seen is the benefits.
我在脑海深处担心过它。我只是没有说出来。但敲敲木头，幸运的是，他一直很好，我们看到的只有收益。
Better than fine, Jeremy says. The drug seems to be working, and he's satisfied.
比好还要好，杰里米说。药物似乎在起作用，他很满意。
If I search my heart of hearts, at least for myself, I'd be dishonest if I said I didn't have superficial motivations exactly as you describe. Maybe not said in those words-- you know, a future leader, more attractive to a mate-- but unless you're a giant, who doesn't want to be taller?
如果我审视内心深处，至少对我自己来说，如果我说我没有你所描述的那种表面化的动机，那就是不诚实。也许不是那样说的——你知道，未来的领导者，对异性更有吸引力——但除非你是巨人，否则谁不想更高一点呢？
But does it feel weird to be kind of like feeding into that? Like feeding into those--
但这感觉很奇怪吗？感觉像是在迎合那种——
Stereotypes?
刻板印象？
Yeah, those societal clamoring for more.
是的，那种社会对更多的渴望。
No. No weirder than your trying to look nice today. Why'd you dress so nicely? You're giving into society. It looks you've got some nice shoes on. You've got a collared shirt. And when you picked your glasses, did you pick the most ugly glasses you could pick? No, you tried to pick some nice glasses, right?
不。不比你今天为了看起来好看而做的努力更奇怪。你为什么打扮得这么漂亮？你是在向社会妥协。看起来你穿了双很棒的鞋。你穿了件有领衬衫。当你挑选眼镜时，你选的是你能挑到的最丑的吗？不，你试着挑了些好看的眼镜，对吧？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
We all, to some degrees-- it's a continuum. I don't think there's anything wrong with that.
我们每个人，在某种程度上——这是一个连续谱。我不认为这有什么不对。
But would you have been sad if he had been Scott's height?
但如果他长到斯科特那种身高，你会难过吗？
That stopped the conversation. I offered to stand up for him.
这让谈话中断了。我提出要为他站起来。
This is where I stand up.
这就是我站起来的时候。
No, don't do that. I don't know the word sad. We would have always wondered, maybe? Like, what would have happened?
不，别那样。我不知道“难过”这个词。我们总会想，也许吧？会发生什么？
But it does raise this question of, in a fully pay-to-play society, do you end up with different tiers of people, some of whom have selected characteristics that confer advantages or seem to confer advantages?
但这确实引出了一个问题：在一个完全付费参与的社会里，你最终会得到不同阶层的人吗？其中一些人选择了那些赋予优势或看起来赋予优势的特征。
I get it. This smacks of the whole SAT-gate thing, right? This is all this whole, let me game the system. I want my child to get a 1600 on the SAT. I want my child to go to Harvard. It smacks of that, and I get it. But at the same time, I don't think it's all that sinister. Like, for us, we just didn't want him to be sitting below the steering wheel and being made fun of or something. That's kind of like--
我懂。这听起来像整个SAT考试舞弊案，对吧？这完全就是那种：“让我操纵系统。我想要我孩子SAT考1600分。我想要我孩子上哈佛。”听起来像那种事，我懂。但同时，我不认为这有什么邪恶的。比如，对我们来说，我们只是不想让他坐在方向盘下还要被嘲笑之类的。那就像——
Which is where Jeremy and Laura's opinions about the whole thing line up a lot more. Laura used to blanch when people would ask if Dylan and his little sister were twins. She's two years younger. And Laura hated that her son wore clothes made for boys two years younger. But all of that's in the past now.
而这正是杰里米和劳拉对整件事的观点高度一致的地方。劳拉过去每当人们问迪伦和他小妹妹是不是双胞胎时都会脸色苍白。妹妹比他小两岁。劳拉讨厌她儿子穿两岁小男孩的衣服。但这一切现在都过去了。
Hi.
嗨。
How are you?
你好吗？
This is Dylan.
这是迪伦。
Good to meet you, man.
很高兴见到你，哥们。
15 years old. He came home from school in the middle of the interview still wearing his school uniform-- white polo, shorts. He's 5 foot 6" now. My producer, Sean, sensitive soul that he is, had us stand back-to-back in the living room.
15岁。采访进行到一半时，他穿着校服从学校回家——白色polo衫，短裤。他现在5英尺6英寸（约168厘米）了。我的制片人肖恩，那个敏感的灵魂，让我们在客厅背靠背站着。
The back of Scott's head is going right into your neck. So I wouldn't want to see you guys in an alley fight.
斯科特脑后的位置刚好到你的脖子。所以我可不想在巷子里打架时看到你们俩。
Wow.
哇。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That was hot, Sean. That was a little demeaning.
刚才那招挺狠，肖恩。有点羞辱人。
Sean, I thought we were pals, buddy.
肖恩，我还以为我们是哥们呢，伙计。
Here's the thing. Measuring yourself directly, bodily, against another human being-- it's not a natural situation. As a 43-year-old man standing back-to-back with a 15-year-old, I felt this almost primal humiliation. And just for a second, I thought, did I miss out on something? I felt a little jealous.
事情是这样的。身体上直接与另一个人进行衡量——这不是一种自然的情况。作为一个43岁的男人和一个15岁的孩子背靠背站着，我感到一种几乎原始的羞辱。就那么一秒，我想，我错过了什么吗？我感到了一点嫉妒。
Laura had spread out the charts on the coffee table, inches versus years, Dylan's whole history of growing up, and up, and up from elementary school on, in a laggardly parabola that takes off like a rocket around the time he started the growth hormone. Each dot is a measurement. You know how I'm in the first height percentile for men in America? Dylan started off parked between the third and fifth percentile and ended up nearly at the 50th, almost average. It made him feel proud.
劳拉在咖啡桌上铺开了图表，英寸对比年份，迪伦从小学开始长高、长高、又长高的整个历史，在一个缓慢的抛物线中，在他开始打生长激素的时候像火箭一样起飞。每个点都是一次测量。你知道我处于美国男性身高第一百分位吧？迪伦起初处于第三和第五百分位之间，最后几乎达到了第50百分位，快接近平均水平了。这让他感到自豪。
Because I saw each dot climbing, and it was going up. It was only going up. And that, to me, was like, OK, I'm getting taller. But I'm going to be a little sad that I can't be as tall as I wanted to be. I'd like to be around 5' 10" or 5' 11", for sure. That way, I'm a little bit above average.
因为我看到每个点都在攀升，而且只在往上走。对我来说，这就像是：“好吧，我在变高。”但我会有点难过，因为我长不到我想要的高度。我肯定想长到5英尺10英寸或5英尺11英寸。那样，我就稍微高于平均水平了。
I've never thought about it that way. What height do I want to be? How average would I like to be? This demand-side attitude about height was alien to me. And standing there, between this giant 5 foot 6" child's mastodon-like shoulder blades, I thought about what had brought me here underneath my indignation, my short identitarianism.
我从没那样想过。我想要多高？我多想接近平均水平？这种对身高的需求侧态度对我来说很陌生。站在那里，在这位巨大的5英尺6英寸的孩子像乳齿象般的肩胛骨之间，我思考是什么把我带到了这里，在我的愤怒、我的矮个子认同之下。
Here's the thing I've glossed over a bit-- the downsides of being short. I took some hard punches to the stomach in elementary school. I often feel taken less seriously by taller people in professional situations. I prefer phone meetings for that very reason. I pretty much know that I've had friendships with women that might have been more than friendships if I'd been a few inches higher off the dance floor.
这里有些事情我略过了一点——矮个子的坏处。我在小学里没少挨揍。在职业场合，我经常觉得被高个子人轻视。我更喜欢电话会议，原因也正是如此。我非常确定，如果我能高出舞池几英寸，我和某些女性的友谊本可以超越友谊。
I've watched the libido drain from my date's eyes as we stand up from the restaurant table after dessert. I've been judging these people, these parents, trying to check every box, buy every advantage. But there was a moment a long time ago when my parents thought about putting me on growth hormone when I was little-- littler-- and they didn't.
我看着我的约会对象在甜点后从餐桌旁站起来时，眼里的欲望一点点流失。我一直在审判这些人，这些父母，试图勾选每一个框，买下每一个优势。但很久以前，在我还是个小孩子的时候，我父母也考虑过给我打生长激素，那时候他们没有这么做。
I have this really strong memory of their telling me they'd looked into it. We were in a car. This would have been the mid-'80s in Virginia. I remember an apple orchard on our left, a fairground on our right, and my mom telling me they'd considered it and decided against it. I remember thinking, why are you telling me this?
我有这样一个强烈的记忆，他们告诉我他们研究过。我们在一辆车里。那应该是80年代中期的弗吉尼亚州。我记得左边是一个苹果园，右边是一个游乐场，我妈妈告诉我他们考虑过并决定不做。我记得我当时在想，你们为什么要告诉我这个？
It's like the moment I became short, the first time I really knew. It was official. Doctors had been consulted, powerful elixirs considered. Maybe none of that should have come as a surprise. I'm the outlier amongst my siblings. My brother Robert is 6 foot 1". Even my little sister Holland is taller than I am. They take after my dad, who, at 5' 11", is a full foot taller than my mom.
这就像我意识到自己很矮的那一刻，我真正知道的第一时间。它是官方的。医生被咨询过了，强力灵药被考虑过了。也许这些都不该让我惊讶。在我的兄弟姐妹中我是个异类。我哥哥罗伯特6英尺1英寸。甚至我的小妹妹霍兰德都比我高。他们随我父亲，他5英尺11英寸，比我母亲整整高出一英尺。
In all these years, we've never talked about that decision. Why didn't they want me to get taller? Why didn't they make the choice Dylan's parents did? I went home, and I asked my mom about that conversation in the car.
这些年来，我们从未谈论过那个决定。他们为什么不想让我变高？为什么他们没有做出迪伦父母那样的选择？我回家问了我妈妈关于车里那次谈话的事。
See, I have no memory of this at all. How did that conversation come up? I'm driving you home from school and I go, by the way?
你看，我完全没有这段记忆。那次谈话是怎么提起来的？是我送你放学回家然后我说，顺便一提？
You know how moms have a way of making the pivotal chapters in your personal history seem less pivotal and more totally apocryphal? Yeah, it was that thing. My mom, very convincingly, debunked my big origin story of how I became short. The timeline was wrong. The location was wrong. The only true part was, once upon a time, I found out I was short. And I'm clearly more hung up on it than I thought I was.
你知道妈妈们总有办法让那些你人生中的关键章节看起来不那么关键，反而显得完全是虚构的？是的，就是那回事。我妈妈非常有说服力地驳倒了关于我如何变矮的大起源故事。时间线不对。地点不对。唯一真实的部分是，很久以前，我发现自己很矮。而且显然我对此比我想象的要执着得多。
But mom confirmed they did decide not to treat me, and we must have talked about it back then. I wanted to know why they didn't treat me. And the answer was pretty simple. When I was about 10, my pediatrician sent me to an endocrinologist to check my growth hormone levels because I was small, and doctors like to check every box.
但妈妈确认他们确实决定不治疗我，我们当时肯定聊过。我想知道为什么他们不治疗我。答案很简单。我大约10岁时，儿科医生把我转诊给内分泌科医生检查我的生长激素水平，因为我很小，医生喜欢检查每一个项目。
So I got tested. I was normal, in terms of hormone levels, anyway, and that's it. They didn't pursue it further. Also, my father was a pharmaceutical researcher who tested experimental medications. My mom was a nurse. They know about this stuff. And this was right after the stories came out about the tainted growth hormone from cadavers.
所以我做了检查。从激素水平来看，我是正常的，就这样。他们没再追究。而且，我父亲是一位测试实验药物的药物研究员。我母亲是护士。他们了解这些东西。那正是在有关尸体生长激素污染的报道传出之后。
I had just listened to those stories. And it was kind of a gut thing. It was kind of like, well, it took them 25 years to figure that out that we had this issue. It took them 25 years. So am I going to wait 25 years to find out, oh, here's a really bad consequence of growth hormone?
我刚好听到了那些故事。那是一种直觉。这就像是，好吧，他们花了25年才弄清楚我们有这个问题。花了25年。所以我还要等25年才能发现，哦，原来生长激素有一个非常糟糕的后果吗？
Of the synthetic.
合成的。
Right.
没错。
Of the synthetic. And we couldn't foresee it. And I had a healthy son who was thriving, I thought. And he was a sharp guy, and I didn't want to screw it up.
合成的那种。我们无法预见它。我有一个正在成长、我认为茁壮成长的健康儿子。他是个聪明的孩子，我不想搞砸它。
My parents were trying to protect me by doing nothing, the same way Laura and Jeremy were trying to protect Dylan by doing something, something elemental, making him bigger.
我父母通过什么都不做来试图保护我，就像劳拉和杰里米试图通过做点什么来保护迪伦一样，做点基本的、让他变得更大的事。
But for my mom, there's something else. She doesn't think of what might have happened if she'd made me bigger. She thinks about what might have been lost if she had.
但对我妈妈来说，还有别的事。她想的不是如果她让我变大可能会发生什么。她想的是，如果她真的那么做了，可能会失去什么。
It's always been interesting to me to see genes will out, you know what I mean? You know, when you say, wow, you do that? And my dad did that. It's like a physical thing that somebody does, or the attitude they have, or the way they handle their hands. Those are genes coming out. That I'd like to see. They're familiar to me.
对我来说，看到基因表现出来一直很有趣，你懂我的意思吗？你知道，当你感叹：“哇，你做那个动作的样子？和我爸爸一样。”那是一种肢体行为，或是他们的态度，或是他们处理手势的方式。那些是展现出来的基因。那是我喜欢看到的。它们对我来说很熟悉。
They're familiar to me too. I remind myself of people I've known-- my grandfather, my uncle, my mom. I've got their bodies. I'm built on their blueprints, reliable blueprints that delivered several generations of tiny living things from primordial slime to this crazy, risky, present moment. That's no small thing. All I know is this is the box I came in, and I like it in here, I think.
它们对我来说也很熟悉。我想起了我认识的人——我的祖父、我的叔叔、我的母亲。我拥有他们的身体。我建立在他们的蓝图之上，那些可靠的蓝图将几代微小的生命从原始粘液运送到这个疯狂、冒险、当下的时刻。那可不是什么微不足道的小事。我只知道这就是我所在的容器，我觉得我很喜欢待在这里。
Scott Brown is a writer producer on the Hulu series Castle Rock. His young adult novel about a super short kid who grows freakishly tall in a year is called XL.
斯科特·布朗是Hulu剧集《城堡石》的编剧兼制片人。他那本关于一个超矮的孩子在一年内长得畸形高大的青年小说叫《XL》。
Coming up, when something shrinks, and shrinks, and shrinks, it can undo a 900-page law, and more about the power of tinyness. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，当某样东西不断缩小、缩小、再缩小，它可以推翻一部900页的法律，以及更多关于微小的力量。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "Small Things Considered," stories in defense of the little and the Lilliputian. We've arrived at Act two of our show.
这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《细微考量》，捍卫微小和微型事物的故事。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Let's give them nothing to talk about.
第二幕，让他们无话可说。
David Kestenbaum has this story about something that got shrunk to exactly as small as something could possibly be shrunk with huge consequences that are playing out right now, this very moment. Here's David.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）有一个关于某样东西的故事，它被缩小到了极致，产生了大得惊人的后果，而这后果正发生在你我此刻。下面是大卫。
This thing that got made small? It's a tax. A couple years ago, the government set it to zero-- 0 dollars, 0 cents-- which makes what follows so remarkable. How could a tax so small it doesn't actually exist cause any trouble? But before I explain-- and since this show is about the importance of small things-- let me just confess here how much I love zero.
这个被变小的东西？是一个税。几年前，政府把它设为零——0美元0美分——这让接下来的事变得如此非凡。一个根本不存在的微小税款怎么会引起麻烦呢？但在我解释之前——既然这个节目是关于细微事物的重要性——让我在这里承认我有多爱“零”。
It's unlike any other number in its capacity for destruction. 0 times anything is 0. No matter how big, it always wins. And even better is dividing. When I was a kid in math class, I'd like to put 1 divided by 0 into my calculator. It would show E for Error, because 1 divided by 0? There is no answer to that. It's undefined. Divide by any other number, and you're fine. 1 divided by 2, for instance, or 57, or 693.
它不同于任何其他数字的破坏力。0乘以任何东西都是0。无论多大，它总是赢家。更好的是除法。小时候数学课上，我喜欢把1除以0输入计算器。它会显示E代表错误，因为1除以0？没有答案。它是未定义的。除以任何其他数字都没问题。比如1除以2，或57，或693。
But put a zero in, and it just blows up. Mathematicians call this kind of situation a singularity, where the math is not well-behaved. In fact, it stops making sense. There are singularities inside black holes, but I never heard of a real world example outside of that until December 14 last year.
但输入零，它直接爆炸。数学家把这种情况称为“奇点”，数学不再表现良好。事实上，它变得毫无意义。黑洞内部存在奇点，但我直到去年12月14日才听说现实世界中的例子。
A law that brought health care to millions of Americans has been struck down by a US judge. The judge has ruled it unconstitutional.
一项为数百万美国人带来医疗保健的法律被美国法官推翻。法官裁定其违宪。
Maybe you remember this. A judge in Texas ruled that the entire Affordable Care Act violated the US Constitution. This was big news, and it immediately got appealed. But the signature domestic policy achievement of the entire Obama presidency, the thing that right now is giving millions of Americans health insurance, that whole thing, this judge was saying, it was unconstitutional, had to go. And the thing that set all this off? A zero.
也许你记得这个。德克萨斯州的一位法官裁定整个《平价医疗法案》（Affordable Care Act）违反了美国宪法。这是大新闻，并立即被上诉。但作为整个奥巴马政府最标志性的国内政策成就，也就是目前让数百万美国人拥有医疗保险的东西，法官却说它违宪，必须取消。而这一切的起因？一个零。
Last year, Congress reduced the penalty tax for not having health insurance to zero. The judge ruled that without--
去年，国会将不购买医疗保险的罚款税降到了零。法官裁定，如果没有——
Let me explain how a zero could blow up an entire law. When Obamacare, the Affordable Care Act, was written almost a decade ago, it included this thing that people called the mandate, which basically said, you have to have health insurance. And if you don't, you've got to pay a fine. In 2016, the average fine paid was a little over $700.
让我解释一个零是如何摧毁整部法律的。当奥巴马医改（即《平价医疗法案》）在大约十年前写好时，它包含了一个被称为“个人强制购买令”的内容，基本含义是：你必须购买医疗保险。如果不买，就得交罚款。2016年，支付的平均罚款略高于700美元。
Opponents of the health care law took issue with that part saying, the government can't just force people to buy something they may not want. All this went to the Supreme Court, which ruled it was OK because-- and this is key-- the mandate could be viewed as a tax. The government has lots of taxes. This is one of them, which felt like the end of it.
医疗保健法的反对者对此提出异议，称政府不能强迫人们购买他们可能不想要的东西。这一切都闹到了最高法院，法院裁定它是合法的，因为——这一点至关重要——该条款可被视为一种税。政府有很多税种。这是其中之一，看起来事情到此为止了。
And it was, until this other thing happened that seemed unrelated. In 2017, Republicans passed their big tax cut bill. And one of the taxes in there that they cut-- this was just a sentence-- was the mandate, the fine that you have to pay if you don't have insurance. They cut it to zero. It really does seem like most lawmakers in Congress did not understand that this one little change could be the basis for getting all 900-plus pages of the ACA ruled unconstitutional.
确实如此，直到发生了另一件似乎不相关的事情。2017年，共和党通过了大规模减税法案。其中一项被削减的税——仅仅是一句话——就是这个个人强制购买令，即你不买保险必须交的罚款。他们把它降到了零。看起来国会中大多数议员确实不明白，这一个微小的改变竟然会成为推翻整部ACA法律（超过900页）的基础。
I couldn't find any record of lawmakers even mentioning it in the floor debate or the news coverage. One person who did see that, who put together how zero could undo the whole law, was someone not in Washington at all, a guy in Wisconsin, Misha Tseytlin, who then was the state solicitor general. I found him on Facebook. His profile picture was from an Ultimate Frisbee tournament.
我找不到任何议员在国会辩论或新闻报道中提及它的记录。有一个人注意到了这一点，他将零如何撤销整部法律整合起来，他甚至不在华盛顿，而是威斯康星州的一位律师，米沙·蔡特林（Misha Tseytlin），他当时是州副总检察长。我在Facebook上找到了他。他的头像是在一场终极飞盘比赛中拍的。
He politely declined to comment. But from legal filings, we know his basic argument. Tseytlin's logic was that, if the tax is zero, then there is no tax. And what you're left with in the law is this line that basically says, people shall buy health insurance. That was OK as part of a tax, like, you shall buy health insurance, or pay a penalty. But now the tax was zero, the text of the law was simply telling people to buy health insurance-- unconstitutional.
他礼貌地拒绝发表评论。但从法律文件中，我们知道他的基本论点。蔡特林的逻辑是，如果税率是零，那么就没有税。而法律留下的部分基本就是：“人们应购买医疗保险。”这作为税的一部分是没问题的，比如：“你应购买医疗保险，否则缴纳罚款。”但现在税变成了零，法律条文仅仅是告诉人们去买保险——违宪。
That is how a tax of zero ends up in a federal appeals court. Most of America's kind of in the courtroom, too-- 18 red states on one side, 16 blue states on the other. I reached out to someone involved in the case, Nick Bagley, professor at the University of Michigan Law School. I talked to him about the part of the case that I find so transfixing.
这就是一个零税率最终出现在联邦上诉法院的原因。美国的大多数人都像是在法庭里，18个红州在一方，16个蓝州在另一方。我联系了案件的一位相关人士，密歇根大学法学院的教授尼克·巴格利（Nick Bagley）。我和他谈到了这个案件中我发现非常迷人的部分。
Can I say the part that stood out to me?
我能说出吸引我的那个部分吗？
Yeah.
可以。
I used to work in physics. And they call it a singularity, like it's a zero in the denominator, like it creates a black hole.
我以前从事物理工作。他们把它称为“奇点”，就像分母中的零，就像它创造了一个黑洞。
Yeah. And you're putting your finger on one of--
是的。你指出了一个——
Bagley, to be clear, thinks the first judge got it totally wrong. He's worked on a brief filed in the appeals case, and he's been writing about it. He pointed out something I honestly had not considered.
巴格利，明确地说，认为第一位法官彻底错了。他参与了一份提交给上诉案件的简报，并一直在写相关文章。他指出了一个我诚实地说没有考虑过的事情。
And I've encouraged, and others have encouraged, Congress, at least the House of Representatives, to pass a bill that would set a $1 tax.
我曾鼓励，其他人也鼓励国会，至少众议院，通过一项将税率设为1美元的法案。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, the House could've passed a bill that made this whole lawsuit go away tomorrow. It would be the jot of a pen. And if the House passes it, and the Senate doesn't want to pass it, well, hang that around the Senate's neck in the next presidential election. Make it their albatross to carry.
是的，众议院本可以明天就通过法案让这整场诉讼消失。那只需笔尖轻轻一点。如果众议院通过了，而参议院不想通过，好吧，就在下届总统选举中把它挂在参议院的脖子上。让它成为他们必须背负的信天翁。
Wait, wait, wait. Hang on. That would work, right? If they just--
等等，等等。等一下。那会奏效，对吧？如果他们只是——
Oh, absolutely.
哦，绝对。
Yeah.
是的。
Absolutely.
绝对。
This whole case goes away if they set it to $1.
如果他们把它设为1美元，整场官司就没了。
Yeah, there's a bunch of different ways you can do it.
是的，有多种不同的方法可以做到。
Or a penny.
或者一分钱。
Set it to $1.
设为1美元。
A penny, too, right?
一分钱也可以吧？
A penny, sure.
一分钱，当然。
But how can it matter that it's $1 or zero, like, really, really?
但设为1美元还是零怎么会有关系呢，真的，真的有关系吗？
It can't, and it shouldn't. And again, you're putting your finger on--
它没有，也不应该有。再次，你指出了——
Well, I understand that legally it might, but it seems crazy, also, that it might.
嗯，我明白法律上可能确实有关系，但它看起来也很疯狂，不是吗？
Yeah. That's one of the great things about the law.
是的。这是法律最伟大的地方之一。
The great things, yeah.
最伟大的地方，是吧。
Well, no, no, no, what I mean what is that, if it seems crazy to you, it probably is. And if the argument is too cute by half, it probably is.
嗯，不，不，不，我的意思是，如果它对你来说显得很疯狂，那它可能就是疯狂的。如果这个论点显得过于取巧，它可能就是过于取巧。
I talked to Bagley back in July on the day that the appeals court heard the case. We listened together online. The arguments the lawyers made were all about standing, severability doctrine, the meaning of the word shall. What did Congress intend when it set the tax to zero? It did not go well for the Affordable Care Act, for Bagley's side. You could tell from the judge's questions. Bagley's exact words while we listened included things like--
我在7月份上诉法院审理此案的那天采访了巴格利。我们在网上一起听了。律师们提出的论点全是关于诉讼资格、可分割性原则、“应”这个词的含义。国会将税设为零时意图是什么？对平价医疗法案来说，对巴格利这一方来说，情况不妙。从法官的提问中就能看出来。我们在听的时候巴格利的原话包括像——
Oh, Jesus.
哦，天哪。
And--
还有——
This is really bad. This is really bad.
这真的很糟。这真的很糟。
And finally--
最后——
This is about as bad as you could expect from an oral argument.
这大概是你口头辩论中能预料到的最糟糕的情况了。
Thank you, your honor.
谢谢您，法官阁下。
He was truly surprised. He thought the legal argument that zero could take down the whole law was, quote, "weak to the point of frivolousness." To Randy Barnett, though, this all seems totally logical. Barnett is a professor at Georgetown Law and has been vocal on the other side. If the tax is zero, Barnett says, the mandate's unconstitutional. He doesn't think the court can strike out just that one part of the law, so the whole thing has to go.
他确实感到惊讶。他认为“零可以推翻整部法律”这一法律论点是“弱到琐碎的地步”。然而，对兰迪·巴内特（Randy Barnett）来说，这一切显得完全合乎逻辑。巴内特是乔治城大学法学院的教授，在另一方一直很活跃。巴内特说，如果税是零，那么强制条款就是违宪的。他不认为法院可以只删掉法律的那一部分，所以整部法律都得取消。
To me, it seems quite reasonable because it's a straightforward application of severability doctrine as I understand it.
对我来说，它看起来相当合理，因为它是据我理解的对可分割性原则的直接应用。
People on the other side feel like this case is an example of weird legal reasoning being used to get to a particular conclusion. Are there other legal decisions that look that way to you?
另一方的人觉得这个案例是一个为了达到特定结论而使用奇怪法律推理的例子。还有其他看起来那样的法律判决吗？
Yeah. I would say that any decision that says that Congress has the power, under its power to regulate commerce among the several states--
有。我会说，任何判决只要说国会根据其在各州之间监管商业的权力拥有这种权力——
Short answer, yes, which is to say, liberals have their examples of what they see as activist judges inventing bizarre arguments, and so do conservatives, and libertarians like Barnett, and everyone else.
简短回答，是的。也就是说，自由派有他们眼中的激进法官发明奇异论点的例子，保守派也有，像巴内特那样的自由意志主义者也有，每个人都有。
He told me about this case that he argued before the Supreme Court, and lost 6 to 3. The court ruled that a woman in California couldn't grow medical marijuana at her own house in her own garden to take for her own back pain because of the Interstate Commerce Clause of the Constitution.
他告诉了我这个他向最高法院辩论但以6比3败诉的案件。法院裁定，加利福尼亚州的一名妇女不能因为宪法中的《州际商业条款》而在自己的花园里种植医用大麻来治疗自己的背痛。
That sounds a little crazy to me. And yet, those kinds of rulings happen all the time.
这听起来对我来说有点疯狂。然而，那种判决却一直在发生。
Give me another one.
再给我一个例子。
How much airtime am I going to get?
我还能有多少播出时间？
I asked Barnett what he made of the fact that this case is how we are deciding whether millions of Americans will have health insurance, and that it all seemed to stem, in some way, from the weird power of zero.
我问巴内特，对于我们现在正通过这种方式决定数百万美国人是否拥有医疗保险，而且这一切似乎在某种程度上源于“零”的怪异力量，他怎么看。
Does it seem odd to you that we are in this position?
这情况对你来说显得奇怪吗？
Define odd. What do you mean?
定义奇怪。你是说？
It just seems odd that somehow there would be a difference between Congress setting a tax to a penny and zero.
这只是看起来很奇怪，不知何故国会将税设为一分钱和零会有所不同。
Whenever you have a distinction, there's going to be marginal cases in which that distinction could make a difference, and the distinction could look arbitrary. That's just the way law works. It works that way all the time. You're speeding, by the way, when you go 36 miles an hour in a 35 mile-an-hour zone. But why is 36 miles an hour-- why is that a terrible speed when 35 miles an hour is perfectly OK?
每当你做出区分，总会有边缘案例，在这种边缘案例中这种区分可能会产生影响，而且这种区分看起来可能很武断。这就是法律运作的方式。它一直都是这样运作的。顺便说一下，当你在35英里限速区开到36英里时，你就是在超速。但为什么36英里是可怕的速度，而35英里却是完全可以的？
It feels a little different somehow.
这感觉有点不同。
You could say that-- well, I'm not sure how to respond to that.
你可以那么说——嗯，我不确定该怎么回应。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm not sure how to ask it, either.
我也不确定该怎么问。
You're entitled to your feelings.
你有权拥有你的感觉。
Here are my feelings. Having big things like this decided in the courts on legal grounds that most people will never understand-- it does not seem ideal to me. The appeals court is supposed to issue its ruling any day now. It seems quite possible this thing is headed for the Supreme Court.
这是我的感觉。让法院在大多数人永远无法理解的法律基础上决定这种大事——这对我来说看起来并不理想。上诉法院预计随时会发布裁决。这件事很有可能闹到最高法院。
It's like this little tax set to zero has created a legal wormhole with red states gathered on one side, blue states on the other, a vortex of high-level legal math in the middle. I worry it's going to suck us all into some other dimension. We'll cross some event horizon from which there is no return. It'll tear our atoms apart. It'll tear us apart. Either that, or a neatly typed opinion will come out some Tuesday morning in June.
这就像这个设为零的微小税收创造了一个法律虫洞，红州聚集在一边，蓝州在另一边，中间是一个高级法律数学的漩涡。我担心它会把我们都吸进另一个维度。我们将跨越某种无法返回的事件视界。它会把我们的原子撕裂。它会把我们撕碎。要么那样，要么某个六月的周二早上，一份整齐打印的判决书就会出来。
David Kestenbaum is the executive editor of our show.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的执行编辑。
Act 3, What the Eye Can't See.
第三幕，肉眼看不见的东西。
So we end our show today with this last story of small things that are anything but small from Lilly Sullivan.
所以，我们今天以莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）讲述的最后一个关于微小事物却一点也不微小的故事作为节目的结尾。
When I was in my early 20s, I spent a lot of my time looking at job postings online. I'd read the qualifications section-- leadership skills, self-starter, results-oriented. And then I'd look at myself-- broke, weird, shy to the point of silence-- and miss the deadline, which is when I stumbled on a story called "The Job Application." It's by this writer, Robert Walser.
在我20岁出头时，我花了很多时间在网上看招聘信息。我会阅读任职资格部分——领导技能、自我驱动、结果导向。然后看看我自己——破产、古怪、害羞到沉默——然后错过了截止日期，就在那时我偶然发现了一个叫《求职信》的故事。作者是罗伯特·瓦尔泽（Robert Walser）。
The story is told in the form of a cover letter, but instead of selling himself, he just offers an honest assessment of who he is.
故事以求职信的形式讲述，但与兜售自己不同，他只是对自己是谁进行了诚实的评估。
"Esteemed gentlemen, I am a poor, young, unemployed person. Large and difficult tasks I cannot perform, and obligations of a far-ranging sort are too strenuous for my mind. I'm not particularly clever. And first and foremost, I do not like to strain my intelligence overmuch. I'm a dreamer rather than a thinker, a zero rather than a force, dim rather than sharp. The passion to go far in the world is unknown to me."
“尊敬的先生们，我是一个贫穷、年轻、失业的人。困难的大任务我干不了，那种深远的义务对我的大脑来说太费劲了。我不太聪明。而且最重要的是，我不想让我的智力过度劳累。我是一个梦想家而不是思想家，是一个零而不是一股力量，是暗淡而不是尖锐。那种想要在这个世界上大展宏图的激情，我一无所知。”
I remember thinking, you're not supposed to tell people that stuff. He was being funny and mocking the whole song and dance. But at the same time, he wasn't making it up. He needed a job.
我记得当时想，你不该告诉人们这些。他写得很有趣，是在嘲弄整套求职把戏。但与此同时，他并没有编造。他需要一份工作。
He ends the letter, "Well, so now you know what sort of a person I am. I am sincere and honest, and I'm aware that this signifies precious little in the world in which we live. So I shall be waiting, esteemed gentlemen. Your respectful servant, positively drowning in obedience."
信末他写道：“好吧，现在你们知道我是什么样的人了。我真诚且诚实，我知道这在我们要生活的这个世界上意义微不足道。所以我将静候佳音，尊敬的先生们。你们恭敬的仆人，沉溺于顺从之中。”
I know almost nothing about this writer, but I loved him for writing this because the thing is, feeling so worthless at that age-- it was terrifying, when your brain isn't orderly and results-oriented, like an effective human's. I'd have a rough shift temping or waitressing. People can be awful when you're at the bottom. And I'd come home just dreading the rest of my life, and he got that.
关于这位作家我几乎一无所知，但我爱他写下这些，因为问题的关键是，在那样的年纪感到如此毫无价值——那太可怕了，当你的大脑不像一个高效的人类那样有条理和结果导向时。我在做临时工或服务员时会有很艰难的轮班。当你身处底层时，人们可以很糟糕。我回到家只觉得对余生感到恐惧，而他懂。
I started reading more of his stuff. One of my favorites is a novel about boys in a school where they're training to be servants. He wrote, "In one thing, we pupils are all similar. We are small, small all the way down the scale to utter worthlessness. One thing I do know for certain-- in later life, I shall be a charming, utterly spherical zero."
我开始读更多他的作品。我最喜欢的一部小说是关于一所培训仆人的学校里的男孩。他写道：“在一点上，我们学生都一样。我们很小，在价值上一直小到彻底的一文不值。有一件事我敢肯定——在以后的生活中，我将是一个迷人、彻底球形的零。”
Robert Walser-- turns out he's Swiss, born in 1878. And for a moment, it looked like he was going to be the next big thing. Kafka, who was younger than him, was a fan. When Kafka came onto the scene, one critic back then explained Kafka by saying, hey, this guy's kind of like Robert Walser. And there was this delighted absurdity to his work.
罗伯特·瓦尔泽——原来他是瑞士人，1878年出生。有一阵子，他看起来要成为下一个大人物。比他年轻的卡夫卡是他的粉丝。当卡夫卡进入文坛时，一位评论家解释卡夫卡说：嘿，这个家伙有点像罗伯特·瓦尔泽。他的作品里有一种令人愉悦的荒诞感。
He'd poke fun at himself for being small, but there was always an edge to it. Worse than being weak, were the people deluded enough to think they're great. It's so pompous. He wasn't mean, exactly, more just entertained by their foolishness. I started to see the world that way, too. But then one day, a few years later, I was at a bookstore, and I saw a new Robert Walser book on the shelf, more of his work translated into English.
他会拿自己小来开涮，但其中总有一种棱角。比虚弱更糟糕的是那些自以为伟大的、被误导的人。这太自命不凡了。他并不刻薄，准确地说，只是对他们的愚蠢感到消遣。我也开始那样看待世界。但几年后的一天，我在书店看到货架上一本新的罗伯特·瓦尔泽的书，更多作品被翻译成了英文。
I started reading the introduction, and it had all this stuff I hadn't known before about his life. It said that Walser had spent the last third of his life in a mental hospital-- schizophrenia. He lived there for 27 years until he died. I was floored and so sad for him. This was the writer I turned to as a roadmap to remind myself that there are people out there like me, and they're fine, and he was the best of our kind of people.
我开始读引言，里面有所有我之前不知道的关于他生活的事情。书上说瓦尔泽生命的最后三分之一是在精神病院度过的——精神分裂症。他在那里住了27年直到去世。我惊呆了，为他感到无比难过。这是我当作人生路线图的作家，用来提醒自己这世界上还有像我这样的人，他们很好，而他是我们这类人中最优秀的。
It freaked me out. Like, that's what life did to him? It turns out Robert Walser had a little early success, but not much after that. Writers liked him, but his books didn't sell well. And he was predictably terrible at marketing himself. After flailing for a while, he left the art scene in Berlin and moved back home to Switzerland. And once he's there, his life starts falling apart.
这让我很害怕。生活竟然对他做了那种事？原来罗伯特·瓦尔泽有过一点早期的成功，但之后就没多少了。作家们喜欢他，但他的书卖得不好。他理所当然地是个营销自己的烂手。挣扎了一段时间后，他离开了柏林的艺术圈，回到瑞士老家。而在那里，他的生活开始崩塌。
He couldn't really get his books published anymore. He starts renting out single rooms, month to month, from old ladies, reduces his possessions to a single suitcase. He's unhappy, alone all the time, mentally shaky. He'd get nightmares and stay up all night pacing and muttering to himself. Eventually, he checks himself into a mental hospital. It's 1929.
他再也无法出版作品。他开始从老太太那里按月租住单间，把财产缩减到一个手提箱。他不快乐，一直孤独，精神不稳定。他会做噩梦，彻夜踱步，自言自语。最后，他在1929年住进了精神病院。
He asks the staff to put him in the shared dorm because-- this breaks my heart-- he's afraid to be alone. They diagnose him with schizophrenia. He's there voluntarily at first, but later, he gets committed against his will, kicking and screaming as they force him into the car for the transfer. He spends the rest of his life in a sanitarium.
他要求工作人员把他安排在公共宿舍，因为——这让我心碎——他害怕孤独。他们诊断他患有精神分裂症。最初他是自愿待在那儿的，但后来，他被强制收治，在转移过程中连踢带打、尖叫抗拒。他在疗养院度过了余生。
There's a story that, when people encouraged him to write again, he said, I'm not here to write. I'm here to be mad. And the world forgot about him, and then he died, on Christmas Day, actually, in 1956. He goes for a walk outside of his asylum, and he collapses. A couple kids find his body in a field of snow. Someone actually took a photo. Robert Walser is lying face up, one arm outstretched, dark clothes against white snow, his hat a few feet away.
有个故事说，当人们鼓励他再次写作时，他说：“我不是来写作的。我是来发疯的。”世界忘记了他，然后他在1956年的圣诞节那天去世了。他去精神病院外散步，然后倒下了。几个孩子在雪地里发现了他的尸体。有人甚至拍了一张照片。罗伯特·瓦尔泽脸朝上躺着，一只手臂伸展，深色的衣服映衬着白雪，帽子在几英尺外。
The book I was looking at had something else, something eerie. I didn't know what to make of it. After Walser died, a nurse in one of his hospitals came forward with these strange scraps of paper. His sister had a shoebox full of them too-- hundreds of little scraps, used postcards, business cards, old calendar pages ripped in half. And those little shreds were just covered in ant-like pencil markings, dense little rows of tiny slashes and ticks, packed onto shreds of paper. Everyone thinks it's just mad-man scrawl, and they put the papers away.
我正在看的书里还有些别的东西，有些令人不安的东西。我不知道该作何感想。瓦尔泽去世后，他住过的一家医院的护士拿出了这些奇怪的纸条。他姐姐也有一鞋盒——数百张小纸条，旧明信片、名片、被撕成两半的旧日历页。那些小碎纸片上密密麻麻画满了蚂蚁般的铅笔标记，细小的斜线和刻痕，挤满在碎纸上。大家都觉得这只是疯子的乱涂乱画，就把纸收了起来。
A few months later, his friend, who, for years, was one of the only people who really visited him in the hospital, publishes a blown-up photo of one of these scraps in a Swiss literary magazine. "Undecipherable," he writes, "a product of Walser's schizophrenia." But when the magazine comes out, a grad student writes in saying, Wait, I can read this. I think those scratchings are letters.
几个月后，他的一个多年来几乎是唯一真的去医院探望他的人，在一家瑞士文学杂志上发表了一张这些纸条之一的放大照片。“无法辨认，”他写道，“是瓦尔泽精神分裂症的产物。”但当杂志出版时，一位研究生写信来说：等等，我能读懂这个。我想那些刻痕是字母。
He got the papers and spent months staring at 24 pages trying to decipher the tiny handwriting. It turned out to be an entire novel. But there were still hundreds more scraps. It wasn't until the 1980s that someone tackled the rest of them, another grad student named Bernhard Echte, 21 at the time. He'd actually been on his way to becoming a doctor. But when he discovered Robert Walser, he stopped that life in its tracks, switched to literature to spend more time with Robert Walser.
他拿到了纸片，盯着24页看了几个月试图破解那细小的手写体。结果发现那是一整部小说。但还有数百张纸片。直到1980年代，才有人开始研究剩下的部分，一个名叫伯恩哈德·埃希特（Bernhard Echte）的研究生，当时21岁。他本来在走向成为医生的路上。但当他发现罗伯特·瓦尔泽时，他的人生轨迹完全改变，转修文学，只为了能和罗伯特·瓦尔泽待在一起。
Because I was-- normal literature, normal text, notes-- I think most of them are boring. But Robert Walser, he's melancholic. He's funny. He is writing about everything and about nothing. And I started to read him when I was 17, and I read for him almost every day since then.
因为——正常的文学、正常的文本、笔记——我觉得大多数都很无聊。但罗伯特·瓦尔泽，他是忧郁的。他是幽默的。他在写一切，又似乎什么都没写。我17岁开始读他，从那以后我几乎每天都读。
He talked to the archive where the shreds are being kept, and they agreed to let him see them, try to decipher some more. And when he sees them for the first time, he's stunned. The writing is microscopic, each letter just a speck, about two millimeters at first, and as the years go by, they get smaller, down to 1 millimeter-- these tiny bold characters, like miniature Japanese calligraphy.
他联系了保存碎纸的档案馆，他们同意让他查看，试着解读更多。当他第一次看到它们时，他惊呆了。字迹极其微小，每个字母只是一个小点，起初大约两毫米，随着岁月的推移，它们变得更小，缩减到1毫米——这些细小的粗体字符，像微型日文书法。
But the really difficult fact is the density of the lines because there's no distance between the lines.
但真正困难的是线条的密度，因为行与行之间没有距离。
Right, because if the letters are a millimeter, the pencil marking must be half a millimeter.
没错，因为如果字母是1毫米，铅笔标记必须是0.5毫米。
Yes, yes. And this is very, very difficult because the pencil is not as sharp as it should be.
是的，是的。这非常非常困难，因为铅笔不够尖。
He brought that up a few times. Like, couldn't he sharpen his pencil?
他提过好几次。比如，他不能把铅笔削尖吗？
And this is the problem because you never know what letter is there and how many. But if you can read, you can read it because you don't spell letter for letter, but you identify the form of the word.
这就是问题所在，因为你永远不知道那里是什么字母，有多少个。但如果你能读懂，你就能读懂，因为你不是逐字逐字母拼写的，而是识别单词的形式。
You can't identify the individual letters, but somehow when you look at them all together, sometimes you can tell what it says. A word will reveal itself. He started working on it full time with a partner. They'd sit at typewriters across from each other in a little room filled with cigarette smoke, bent over these magnifying glasses called thread counters, and they'd stare at the words.
你无法辨认单个字母，但不知何故，当你把它们放在一起看时，有时你能分辨出它写的是什么。一个词会显现出来。他和同伴开始全职做这个。他们在一个充满香烟烟雾的小房间里对着打字机坐着，弯腰看着这些被称为“线计”的放大镜，盯着这些词。
When they'd get stumped on a word, which happened constantly, they had the system where they'd rattle off gibberish and random syllables. Bernhard and the other guy would work separately on a scrap for a while, then they'd compare their guesses. If they had come to the same conclusion, they decided it was right.
当他们在一个词上卡住时，这种情况经常发生，他们有一个系统，就是乱说一通胡言乱语和随机音节。伯恩哈德和另一个人会分开研究一张纸条一段时间，然后比较他们的猜测。如果他们得出了相同的结论，他们就判定它是对的。
The project was supposed to take four years. It ended up taking 20. Bernhard did the last six years alone. He had started when he was 21 and finished when he was 41. And when he'd finally finished, those 526 scraps turned into six volumes of work, The Microscripts, 2,000-some pages of stories, comedy, little dramas, a novel about a robber who doesn't steal much of anything.
项目本来应该耗时四年。最终花了20年。伯恩哈德最后六年是一个人做的。他21岁开始，41岁完成。当他终于完成时，那526张纸片变成了六卷作品，《微型手稿》，2000多页的故事、喜剧、小戏剧、一部关于一个什么都不怎么偷的强盗的小说。
I had pictured this writing as sad little notes to no one. But when you read it, it's like Walser's back, happily throwing stones. Like he writes, "I've no use for these graspers. Pleasure-seekers overlook life's true pleasures. They aren't serious, which makes them boring, and they can't help being bored with me, since I'm bored with them."
我曾想象这些写作是悲伤的、没人看的笔记。但当你读它们时，就像瓦尔泽回来了，愉快地扔石头。比如他写道：“我不需要这些贪婪的人。追求享乐的人忽视了生活中真正的快乐。他们不严肃，这使他们很无聊，他们不可避免地对我感到无聊，因为我厌倦了他们。”
Some things scholars have figured out-- Walser wrote most of these scraps before the asylum, so this romantic idea of one man alone, writing his masterpieces while locked away, seems like it didn't happen that way.
学者们已经弄清楚了一些事情——瓦尔泽在住进精神病院之前写了大部分纸条，所以那种关于一个孤独的人被锁起来写出杰作的浪漫想法，似乎并没有发生。
And it seems like he probably wasn't schizophrenic. Bernhard has studied all the medical records. Walser's own doctor thought he was fine and should go home. Psychiatrists who study him now don't think he was schizophrenic either. He didn't really have the symptoms.
他似乎可能并不是精神分裂症患者。伯恩哈德研究了所有的医疗记录。瓦尔泽自己的医生认为他很好，应该回家。现在研究他的精神病学家也不认为他是精神分裂。他并没有真正表现出那些症状。
Also, that thing he's famous for saying, "I'm not here to write. I'm here to be mad"-- people who study him think he likely didn't say that, that it's a myth, and that the truth is he got trapped there for the most infuriatingly mundane reason-- medical bureaucracy. Once he lost his rights, he couldn't get them back, couldn't sign himself out.
还有那句他著名的名言，“我不是来写作的，我是来发疯的”——研究他的人认为他很可能没说过，那是个神话，事实是他被困在那里是因为最令人恼火的平庸原因——医疗官僚主义。一旦他失去了权利，他就无法拿回，无法签出自己。
And during the 27 years he was there, a lot happened in the world-- World War II. That circle of writers who might have known his work, people who might have remembered that he was there, had scattered. Their books were banned. They were living in exile or dying violently. Kafka's family members were killed in the Holocaust.
在他待在那里的27年里，世界上发生了很多事——第二次世界大战。那个可能了解他作品的作家圈子，那些可能记得他还在那儿的人，已经四散而去。他们的书被禁了。他们生活在流亡中或死于暴力。卡夫卡的家人们死于大屠杀。
So some writer no one read anymore, who no one ever really knew in the first place, people had other things to worry about. One scholar told me, she thinks that, at some point, Walser probably could have gotten out of the hospital if he wanted to, but he stopped trying.
所以对于一个没人再读、起初也没人真正认识的作家，人们有别的事要担心。一位学者告诉我，她认为在某个时刻，如果瓦尔泽想走，他本可以离开医院，但他停止了尝试。
I wondered why he spent so many years writing things that even he probably couldn't read. He explained to someone, in those years when he was really depressed, when publishers didn't want his work anymore, he had bad writer's block. He describes it as a cramp in his brain. And he explains that writing this tiny hurts. So he can take the cramp in his brain and put it into his hand, instead. And once he does that, his mind is clear, and he can think again.
我很好奇为什么他花了这么多年写一些连他自己可能都读不懂的东西。他曾向某人解释过，在那几年里，当他极度抑郁、出版社不再想要他的作品时，他有严重的写作障碍。他描述为“大脑抽筋”。他解释说，这样微小的写作很痛苦。所以他可以把大脑里的抽筋转移到手上。一旦他做到了，他的头脑就清晰了，他又能思考了。
On a page of a calendar he'd cut into pieces, he writes about why he did it all in pencil. One day, he figured out that a pen made him nervous-- all those mistakes, cross-outs, in ink.
在一张被他剪成碎片的小日历页上，他写下了为什么他全都用铅笔写。有一天，他发现钢笔让他紧张——所有那些墨水造成的错误和划痕。
But if he used a pencil instead and labored over this tiny writing, he explains, "This labor looked to me like a pleasure, as it were. I felt it would make me healthy. A smile of satisfaction would creep into my soul each time, like a smile of amicable self-derision. It seemed to me, the pencil let me work more dreamily, peacefully, cosily, contemplatively. I believe that the process I just described would blossom into a peculiar form of happiness."
但如果他改用铅笔，并在这种微小的书写上费力，他解释道：“这种劳动在我看来，就像是一种乐趣。我觉得它会让我健康。每次，那种微笑都会爬进我的灵魂，就像一种友好的自嘲微笑。在我看来，我刚才描述的过程会开出一种奇特的幸福之花。”
That his handwriting was small is in close connection with his convictions about life and what is interesting in life. He was not interested in great importance and things which are big and everybody knew about. The interesting things are the small things.
他的手写体之所以小，与他的人生信念以及生活中什么是有趣的息息相关。他不对重要性、宏大的事物以及大家都知道的事情感兴趣。有趣的是微小的事物。
The idea I'd had about his life in the asylum, how he died, how awful it all seemed to me-- Bernhard doesn't see it that way. He's studied Walser his whole life, every letter and document. He even bought the house where Walser once lived, and he lives there now. He knows his life inside and out, and he thinks it's not tragic.
我对他精神病院生活的想象，关于他怎么死、这一切看起来有多糟糕——伯恩哈德并不这么看。他研究了瓦尔泽一辈子，每一封信件和文件。他甚至买下了瓦尔泽曾经住过的房子，现在就住在那儿。他对他的一生了如指掌，他认为那并不悲剧。
He says, Walser usually seems kind of OK. Not happy, exactly, but content. "Life without success," Walser once wrote, "can also be beautiful." His was. There's power in being OK with being nothing. It's honest. And you can't crush nothing. He made his life smaller and smaller until he almost didn't exist anymore, and then he didn't, an utterly spherical zero.
他说，瓦尔泽通常看起来还挺好。算不上快乐，但很满足。“没有成功的生活，”瓦尔泽曾写道，“也可以是美丽的。”他的一生就是。做一个“没什么”的人并感到自在，这其中有一种力量。那是诚实的。你无法摧毁“没什么”。他把生活变得越来越小，直到他几乎不再存在，然后他真的不在了，一个彻底球形的零。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show. Other details about Walser's life and work in her story came from Susan Bernofsky. Thanks to Susan Bernofsky. She has translated eight of his books, and has just written the first-ever English biography of Walser full of the new information she's uncovered. It'll come out in about a year from Yale University Press.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制片人之一。她故事中关于瓦尔泽生活和工作的其他细节来自苏珊·伯诺夫斯基（Susan Bernofsky）。感谢苏珊·伯诺夫斯基。她翻译了他的八本书，并刚刚写了第一部英文版瓦尔泽传记，里面充满了她发现的新信息。一年后将由耶鲁大学出版社出版。
Normal literature, normal texts, notes-- I think most of them are boring.
正常的文学、正常的文本、笔记——我觉得大多数都很无聊。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《此美国生活》，带来更多故事。